so let's give someone a very quick
capsule bio of yours you were born in
Turkey you were an economics professor
at MIT how would you describe your
research uh and the work that you do
well you know I came into economics
because
I was passionate about understanding
democracy and economic prosperity
little did I know when I first came into
economics that you know many of these
topics were not the ones that economists
focused on you know in the 1990s you
know we studied markets and supply and
demand but you know big questions about
democracy and so on who were off the
table but as soon as I started exploring
these issues it was quite obvious to me
that technological change and Innovation
were also at the heart of the problem
and so a lot of my research is about
what triggers technological progress big
innovation breakthroughs and what their
consequences are what their inequality
implications are who wins who loses
and uh a lot of that was academic work
and then it started
being more
amenable to public discourse because
inequality became a major issue in this
country
and technological change is around us
and I think debates about what
technology is doing to our society are
becoming more Central so the power and
progress book is the culmination of all
of this research and thinking
yeah so uh your latest book power and
progress makes an argument that's
similar to frankly an argument I made
when I was running for president in the
last cycle
um now there's this very very big Fisher
or divide one one has when you think
about
technological progress and its effect on
human Prosperity so the main one is hey
every time something gets invented we
become more prosperous it's great and
even if it's not you directly it's going
to be one of these Rising tide lifts all
boats scenarios so we should all
cheerlead for Progress now the other
side of the coin is hey when these
Technologies get adopted they kick
certain people to the curb they make
certain people richer certain firms uh
more Central and and Powerful right now
the main technology people think of and
this is AI and AI is going to benefit a
certain number of the very large Tech
firms uh and their their shareholders
presumably and then there may be lots of
workers who are on the outside looking
in so your book makes a very very
important and I will say comprehensive
historically documented argument about
which of these two we should be looking
at and you say look it's it doesn't
happen on its own it's actually a result
of a lot of social economic and
political choices so if you were to sum
up for people does technology mean that
we all get richer and more prosperous
well your your description and your
emphasis are 100 on target yes indeed
this is very coherent uh consistent with
your emphasis and the way I put it when
discussing this issue is that you have
to have
two potentially conflicting
frames in your mind one is no doubt we
are amazingly
fortunate to be living today rather than
say 300 years ago
and that's largely because of Industrial
Technologies and scientific
breakthroughs that have then been
applied to our lives so we are
beneficiaries of technological progress
we are so much more healthier so much
more comfortable so much more prosperous
so much more secure than people 300 250
years ago but conflicting with that
there is nothing automatic about
technological progress bringing these
gains
during
almost every episode of major
technological transitions what we see is
that a there are many losers from that
process as you pointed out but even more
importantly B the phase of widespread
gains did not arise by itself or
automatically it was almost always a
struggle to get there
so sometimes when we talk about these
issues and I'm sure you got this a lot
Andrew as well you get the question so
are you saying that this time is
different because we've always benefited
from technology in the past so you must
be saying this time is different and
this book is saying no this time is no
different in the past two we've had
these struggles we've had many people
who've been damaged by technology when
it wasn't appropriately used for example
the Industrial Revolution to which we
owe our prosperity led to lower incomes
much harsher working conditions much
lower life expectancy for about 100
years for the working people yeah and
that's what your book painstakingly does
is it goes out through history and says
okay when there was a Great Leap Forward
technologically uh did everyone feel the
benefits
and so you
um you go through major examples and uh
the answer is a lot of the times people
did not feel the benefits starting with
the development of even
Agriculture and and farming uh in Europe
where it turns out that there were some
land owners and then a bunch of Serfs
I mean you know and again you know how
can you expect that
things would be so seamless when almost
all land almost all technology almost
all power was so concentrated and it
wasn't you know another example even
closer to home is the cotton gin the
United States
became the largest exporter of cotton
and the Southern economy was completely
revolutionized by the ability to plant
cotton that could then be cleaned on a
massive scale but who were the producers
where they were the enslaved black
people did they benefit hell no their
conditions became much harsher on Cotton
plantations longer working hours they
were moved to the further Deep South and
of course again
you don't expect their conditions to
improve seamlessly because they were in
an enslaved relationship
so power matters what we're doing with
technology matters AI is so amazing
because it's so versatile so that makes
these issues more important a lot less
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang-up new
guests thank you